86,2 % des candidats ont eu leur
baccalauréat en 2019 dans l'académie de
versailles
mais avant même d'avoir leur diplôme en
poche les lycéens doivent se poser la
question de l'orientation
alors pour les aider à faire leur choix
cergy paris université a proposé à
l'académie de versailles
la mise en place d'un réseau entre
lycées et établissements du supérieur
s'est rendue compte que les acteurs des
lycées et les acteurs des du premier
cycle du supérieur ne se connaissaient
pas forcément toujours le réseau lilly
pour lisser licence regroupe tous les
acteurs de l'orientation du val d'oise
du nord des hauts-de-seine et du nord
des yvelines 70 lycées couvert au total
pour renforcer des actions concrètes et
on se rend compte qu'on a besoin pour
des raisons importantes et notamment
pour diminue le taux d'échec de nos
lycéens en première année quand il
arrive dans leurs études supérieures on
a besoin de s'améliorer
une nouvelle méthode pour souder le
maillage territorial qui vient s'ajouter
à trois autres mesures lancées par
l'académie de versailles formation des
équipes pédagogiques valorisation des
compétences des élèves et ouverture
sociale des grandes écoles qui est
particulier dans cette académie ça va
être le plan de formation très
importante très conséquents pour lequel
on va consacrer des moyens
et puis d'autre part vraiment cette
logique d'across territoriale entre les
établissements scolaires et les
établissements d'enseignement super
le réseau lily lauréats du programme
d'investissements d'avenir est en
expérimentation dans l'académie de
versailles et ses partenaires de la
réunion et mayotte pour pourquoi pas à
se développer sur l'ensemble du
territoire national par la suite